>>> FOER PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
JOYING A WAVE OF SUPPORT AFTER
THE FBI'S SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO,
AND SOME TOP REPUBLICANS WHO
FIRST URGED TRUMP TO WAIT UNTIL
AFTER THE MIDTERMS TO ANNOUNCE
HIS RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN 2024
ARE NOW URGING HIM TO GET IN
SOONER.
CNN'S MELANIE SA NONA JOINS US
NOW.
SO EXPLAIN THE STRATEGY HERE.
>> Reporter: VICTOR, I WOULD SAY
THIS IS MORE OF A PR AND
DEFENSIVE STRATEGY THAN
ANYTHING.
LOOK, REPUBLICANS DO NOT KNOW
WHAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
ON TRUMP OR WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING
INTO, BUT THEY'RE TRYING TO USE
THAT BLACK HOLE TO THEIR
ADVANTAGE, AND THEY THINK THAT
BY TRUMP DECLARING A
PRESIDENTIAL BID NOW THEY CAN
PAINT TRUMP AS A VICTIM AND TRY
TO PAINT THE INVESTIGATION AND A
POTENTIAL INDICTMENT AS NOTHING
MORE THAN JUST A POLITICAL WITCH
HUNT THAT'S DESIGNED TO TAKE HIM
DOWN, AND THIS IS A REALLY RAPID
SHIFT IN THINKING AMONG TRUMP'S
INNER CIRCLE BECAUSE MANY OF
THEM WANTED TRUMP TO WAIT UNTIL
AFTER THE MIDTERMS TO ANNOUNCE
ANY PRESIDENTIAL BID BECAUSE
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT TRUMP
BEING ON THE BALLOT IN NOVEMBER
INSTEAD OF IT BEING A REFERENDUM
ON PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BUT OVER THE
LAST 48 HOURS, WE'VE BEEN TOLD
THAT TRUMP HAS JUST RECEIVED A
BARRAGE OF ENCOURAGEMENT TO RUN
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE, INCLUDING
AT A DINNER LAST NIGHT THAT HE
HAD WITH A GROUP OF HOUSE
CONSERVATIVE MEMBERS.
I TALKED TO ONE OF THOSE
REPUBLICANS THAT WAS AT THE
DINNER LAST NIGHT, REPUBLICAN
JIM BANKS OF INDIANA, AND HERE'S
WHAT HE TOLD ME ABOUT THAT
MEETING WITH TRUMP.
HE AS IN TRUMP TOLD US THAT HIS
MIND IS MADE UP.
IT'S JUST THE TIMING OF WHEN HE
WILL MAKE THAT ANNOUNCEMENT.
MY SENSE IS HE IS FIRED UP AND
READY TO GO, AND HE RECEIVED A
LOT OF ENCOURAGEMENT IN THE ROOM
TO GET OUT SOONER THAN LATER.
NOW, VICTOR, I'M ALSO TOLD THAT
DURING THIS MEETING TRUMP AND
THE GROUP OF HOUSE REPUBLICANS
TALKED ABOUT THE TYPES OF
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT
REPUBLICANS WILL PURSUE IF THEY
RECAPTURE THE MAJORITY IN THE
FALL.
AND SO THIS IS REALLY JUST
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF HOW
REPUBLICANS ARE RALLYING TO
TRUMP'S SIDE IN THE WAKE OF THIS
FBI SEARCH, VICTOR.
>> MELANIE ZANONA WITH THE
REPORTING ON CAPITOL HILL, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH S.E. CUPP AND
CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATOR AND
FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN ADVISER
DAVID URBAN.
WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
DAVID, LET ME START WITH YOU.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT SHOULD GET INTO THE
RACE BEFORE NOVEMBER?
>> NO, VICTOR.
I WOULD URGE THE PRESIDENT NOT
TO GET INTO THE RACE BEFORE
NOVEMBER.
I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT'S
ENTRANCE IN THE RACE WOULD
DEFLECT A LOT FROM THE FOCUS
WHERE IT -- PLACING THE FOCUS
WHERE IT SHOULD BE ON THE RECORD
OF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
RIGHT?
JOE BIDEN HAS HISTORICALLY --
HE'S POLLING THE LOWEST OF ANY
PRESIDENT IN POLLING, IN MODERN
POLLING, EVEN AS FAR BACK AS THE
EISENHOWER YEARS, AND RIGHT
TRACK, WRONG TRACK IN AMERICA,
85% OF AMERICANS BELIEVE THE
COUNTRY IS GOING ON THE WRONG
TRACK.
WITH REALLY BAD NUMBERS LIKE
THAT, YOU WANT TO FOCUS ON THIS
ADMINISTRATION, NOT ON DONALD
TRUMP.
>> S.E., WHAT DO YOU THINK?
DO YOU THINK IT MATTERS?
NO, I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY --
I THINK IT'S SORT OF DELUSIONAL
TO THINK THAT TRUMP IS IN A SILO
AND REPUBLICAN SENATE
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATES ARE
RUNNING WITHOUT HIM OR APART
FROM HIM.
HE'S VERY MUCH INVOLVED IN THESE
RACES.
HE'S ENDORSING MANY CANDIDATES.
HE'S, YOU KNOW, NOT JUST DIPPING
A TOE BUT AN ENTIRE LEG INTO THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
I DON'T THINK ESPECIALLY
REPUBLICAN VOTERS ARE REALLY
SEPARATING TRUMP FROM REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES, SO I DON'T THINK IT
MATTERS ALL THAT MUCH WHEN HE
ANNOUNCES OR NOT.
>> DAVID, YOU TRY TO GET IN
THERE?
>> YEAH, LOOK, I OBVIOUSLY
DISAGREE WITH S.E. ON THAT
POINT, RIGHT?
I THINK THAT CANDIDATES MATTER.
PEOPLE VOTE FOR INDIVIDUAL
CANDIDATES.
THERE ARE SOME WHERE THE
PRESIDENT HAS WADED IN, HE'S
DIPPED A WHOLE LEG AND NOT JUST
A TOE, HAS WADED IN WITH
WHOLEHEARTED SUPPORT.
THERE ARE LOTS OF RACES ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY WHERE THE PRESIDENT
HASN'T WEIGHED IN OR PEOPLE ARE
RUNNING ON THEIR OWN MERITS AND
THEY HAVEN'T WRAPPED THEMSELVES
IN THE CLOAK OF TRUMPISM, AND I
THINK THEY DESERVE A CHANCE TO
BE HEARD BY THE VOTERS AND NOT
DILUTED BY THE MESSAGE OF THIS
RAID OR ANYTHING ELSE FROM NOW
UNTIL ELECTION DAY.
>> LISTEN, ON THIS SEARCH --
>> GOOD LUCK, I MEAN, GOOD LUCK
WITH THAT.
I UNDERSTAND THE DESIRE TO
SEPARATE, YOU KNOW, SOME
CANDIDATES WHO DON'T WANT TO BE
TAINTED BY TRUMP FROM TRUMP
HIMSELF, BUT GOOD LUCK WITH
THAT.
THIS IS ALL HAPPENING AT THE
SAME TIME, NOT IN A VACUUM.
>> WE SAW IT LAST NIGHT.
>> BUT S.E., MY SIMPLE POINT IS
WE SHOULD BE -- IF YOU'RE A
REPUBLICAN, YOU WANT TO RUN ON
THE BIDEN RECORD, NOT ON THE
TRUMP RECORD, RIGHT?
>> OH, I'M NOT DISAGREEING WITH
YOUR STRATEGY, DAVID, I
COMPLETELY AGREE.
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOUR
STRATEGY.
IF I -- YOU KNOW, IF I WERE
ADVISING REPUBLICANS, I WOULD BE
SAYING EXACTLY WHAT YOU ARE.
I'M JUST NOT SURE IT REALLY
MATTERS ALL THAT MUCH WHEN TRUMP
GETS IN.
I THINK HE'S ALREADY LOOMING SO
LARGE OVER THE PARTY, THAT'S
ALL.
>> ON THIS SEARCH SPECIFICALLY,
WE KNOW THAT TRUMP'S BASE, THE
30% OR WHATEVER OF REPUBLICANS,
THEY ARE ENERGIZED BY THIS.
>> YEAH.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THIS BRINGS
SOME OF THOSE REPUBLICANS WHO
WERE STARTING TO SEPARATE AFTER
THE JANUARY 6th HEARINGS
THINKING MAYBE SOMEONE ELSE,
THIS PULLS THEM BACK?
>> I THINK WE'RE -- I THINK
WE'RE MAKING TOO MUCH OF WHAT
THIS MEANS FOR VOTERS WHO WERE
ALWAYS GOING TO VOTE FOR TRUMP,
AND SO OF COURSE THEY'RE
ENERGIZED.
THEY WERE ALWAYS ENERGIZED.
IT'S NOT LIKE THIS -- THEY
NEEDED THIS PICK ME UP.
THEY WERE ALWAYS WITH TRUMP, AND
THIS JUST SOLIDIFIES WHAT THEY
ALWAYS THOUGHT ABOUT THE DEEP
STATE AND THE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, AND THEN I THINK IF
YOU WERE REALLY TURNED OFF BY
JAN 6, SOMETHING LIKE THIS WILL
PROBABLY CONTINUE TO TURN YOU
OFF.
THIS IS AN AWFUL WEEK FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND THE COUNTRY.
I MEAN, HE'S FACING SEVERAL
LAWSUITS, HIS TAX RETURNS ARE
GOING TO BE OVERTURNED, HIS HOME
OFFICE WAS SEARCHED BY THE FBI.
THIS ISN'T GOOD, AND SO I THINK
IF YOU WERE ALREADY GETTING A
WHIFF OF WANTING TO MOVE ON
THINKING THIS GUY'S PROBABLY
CORRUPT AND MAYBE EVEN GOT SOME,
YOU KNOW, FACING SOME CRIMINAL
CHARGES, I THINK THIS CONTINUES
TO PUSH YOU IN THAT DIRECTION.
>> BUT DAVID, TO THAT POINT,
WHY
ARE WE SEEING THE POTENTIAL 2024
OPPONENTS, NIKKI HALEY, FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE, RON
DeSANTIS, FORMER SECRETARY
POMPEO ALL COMING OUT WITH THESE
STATEMENTS DERIDING THE FBI,
DERIDING THE ADMINISTRATION WHEN
THIS COULD HELP THEM IF THEY
JUST STAY SILENT HERE?
>> RIGHT, WELL, I THINK S.E.'S
ANALYSIS OF THIS, I THINK
REPUBLICANS WRIT LARGE CARE A
GREAT DEAL ABOUT OVERREACH FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WRIT
LARGE, RIGHT?
I THINK THAT SMALL GOVERNMENT,
YOU KNOW, REPUBLICANS, SMALL
GOVERNMENT REPUBLICANS FIND THIS
REPUGNANT AND HISTORY OF THE RE
NOTHING LIKE THAT HAS OCCURRED.
I THINK THIS HAS MADE DONALD
TRUMP A SYMPATHETIC CHARACTER,
WHICH IS VERY HARD TO DO.
I THINK IT'S MADE HIM
SYMPATHETIC AMONGST A GREAT DEAL
MORE REPUBLICANS.
YOUR QUESTION AT THE BEGINNING
OF THAT, HAS THIS HELPED THE
PRESIDENT, I THINK THEY HAVE,
VICTOR.
I THINK PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE BEEN
OUTSIDE THE TENT MAY BE MORE
INCLINED TO BE DAMN THE
TORPEDOS, FULL SPEED AHEAD NOW
THAT THIS HAS OCCURRED.
IT'S MY TAKE ON IT.
I DO THINK IT'S HELPED HIM A
GREAT DEAL THIS WEEK.
>> I THINK THIS A TRUMP WORLD
TALKING POINT THAT ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY PEOPLE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE OVERREACH
AND LOSING CONFIDENCE IN THE FBI
AND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT NOW,
THAT IS TRUE AMONGST -- IN MAGA
WORLD, BUT I THINK MOST PEOPLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THINK IF YOU
DIDN'T --
>> S.E., COME OUT OF THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> LET ME FINISH.
IF YOU DIDN'T LEAVE THE WHITE
HOUSE WITH CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY THAT THE
FBI IS COMING TO RAID YOUR HOME
OFFICE.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE THINK
HOLDING EVEN THE PRESIDENT
ACCOUNTABLE IS GOOD.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
THAT'S A SIGN OF A HEALTHY -- OF
A HEALTHY JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
AND A HEALTHY FBI.
I THINK THIS TRUMP WORLD TALKING
POINT THAT THE FBI IS CORRUPT
AND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
COMING FOR AVERAGE AMERICANS.
>> IF THEY DID IT FOR TRUMP,
THEY COULD DO IT TO YOU.
>> IT'S PREPOSTEROUS, AND I
THINK --
>> LISTEN, I'M NOT --
>> WE'RE PARROTING IT AS IF IT'S
A MAJORITY OPINION.
IT'S NOT.
>> I'M NOT GOING THAT FAR, S.E.
WHAT I'M SIMPLY SAYING IS THAT A
WIDE SWATH OF AMERICANS ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT A HISTORICAL
PRECEDENT.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S TRUE.
>> THIS IS A PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS ACT VIOLATION THIS IS
NOT CRIMINAL.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME, S.E.?
>> NO.
>> THEY KICKED DOWN HILLARY
CLINTON'S DOORS TO GET HER
SERVERS.
>> TRUMP SET THE PRECEDENT.
>> S.E., COULD I FINISH?
>> YOU HAVE TOP SECRET
INFORMATION, TOP SECRET
INFORMATION ON HILLARY CLINTON'S
COMPUTER, OKAY?
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE AMILIAR
WITH HOW A SCIF WORKS, S.E.
>> YOU DON'T NEED TO BE
CONDESCENDING, DAVID, I KNOW
WHAT YOU KNOW.
TRUST ME.
>> I'M NOT, I'M SAYING IT IS A
MUCH BIGGER DEAL.
NOBODY RAIDED THE CLINTON HOUSE
IN CHAPPAQUA.
FOR YOU TO SAY --
>> WE DON'T NEED TO COMPARE AND
CONTRAST.
>> S.E., JUST LET ME FINISH.
FOR YOU TO SAY I'M PARROTING
MAGA WORLD TALKING POINTS
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS WRIL WRIT
LARGE ARE CONCERNED.
>> YOU SAID A WIDE SWATH OF
AMERICANS.
>> I SAID REPUBLICANS, S.E.,
REPUBLICANS.
>> HILLARY'S EMAILS, BAD.
TRUMP'S DOCUMENTS, BAD.
SECRET SERVICE TEXTS, BAD.
I WANT TO SEE IT ALL.
I'M PRETTY FAIR AND DOWN THE
MIDDLE ON THIS.
I'M NOT SAYING ONE IS WORSE THAN
THE OTHER.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
IT'S ALL BAD.
BUT I THINK IF YOU'RE GOING TO
APPLY THAT SAME LEVEL OF
SCRUTINY TO HILLARY, WE SHOULD
APPLY IT TO DONALD TRUMP, AND I
DON'T THINK PEOPLE WIDE SWATHS
OF AMERICANS, BELIEVE THAT THE
FBI IS CORRUPT AND COMING FOR
THEM BECAUSE THEY WENT FOR A
PRESIDENT WHO SET THE PRECEDENT
FOR DOING THINGS THAT NO OTHER
PRESIDENT HAD EVER